[Musique]
le nouvel an
là c'est sans relâche on va être sur le
terrain 24 24 tous les jours jusqu'à
vendredi à 00h01 challah
[Musique]
dans la communauté adresse e mail je
donne au monde de poker la laissons la
loi ce qu'en dit le jean bleu la
communication et de masse et c'est
important vous l'avais lâché pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre l'enjeu qui écrit
que ce souci au niveau des
sélectionneurs cette interview with
nature est si importante pour la
population sénégalaise
[Musique]
holly cole a fortement et le challenge
on va y arriver pour la simple raison
que la plage a déjà adhéré à notre cause
la foule a déjà compris que sa
souffrance majeur est due à cette
mauvaise gestion de présence à kseir et
de son régime et la population amène a
conscience que le combat débute à
l'assemblée nationale et en 2024 un
autre chantier en ciel
[Musique]
on prend une assemblée de valeur de
rupture nous sommes jeunes et nous
voulons avoir un changement de mentalité
un changement dans la ville voilà c'est
parce que la commotion ici présent
d'agir on ne nous a pas payé mais on est
là présent de la grc
mais bruxelles - je suis pour la
coordination a mal à moi j'aime bien le
sens des mots ponote pour pouvoir voter
des lois qui formera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
électoralement l impossible actuellement
au sénégal c'est ça la réalité c'est une
construction intellectuelle c'est une
vue de l'esprit actuellement au sénégal
le président aura sa majorité à
l'assemblée il nommera son premier
ministre et il continuera à écrire les
le formidable programme qu'il a acquis
et enfin aujourd'hui de faire émerger le
sénégal certains sont candidats joly des
opposants ils ont été à l'assemblée
nationale le retour de présence dans
cette assemblée nationale pendant cinq
ans ne dépasse pas les 5 % ils le
sortent d'aucune proposition qui puisse
permettre à la démocratie sénégalaise
d'avancé aucune
on veut qu'il ait su combiner travail
non